they say you should never meet your
Heroes but I think when it comes to
Keanu Reeves that really doesn't apply
because there are so many stories of the
Cayman being amazing to people it's hard
to believe he's even of this Earth I
decided to take a closer look at how
Keanu Reeves is like the best person in
the world okay for starters the man is
respectful to women in 2019 photos of
Keanu posing with female fans went viral
on Twitter and for an awesome reason it
was pointed out that when he takes a pic
with any female fan he won't rest his
hand on their shoulder or any part of
their body for that matter instead he
holds his hand a few inches away from
them so they don't feel like their space
is being invaded now this kind of thing
is usually seen as something done by
like nerdy guys or Guys Without enough
confidence to interact with a woman and
yeah that might be true sometimes but
clearly a handsome movie star does not
have that issue Keanu is just flat out
considerate you guys he doesn't want to
make anyone feel uncomfortable
especially when they're meeting someone
who they probably look up to the phrase
respectful King was soon tossed around
Twitter as more and more photos like
this popped up hey speaking of respect
we'd give you crazy amounts of it if you
hit that subscribe button Kiana is not
only nice to individual fans and photos
he's also nice to them in big groups for
example remember when your aunt sends
you a text that read the guy from The
Matrix just arranged a bus ride for us
to LA and you were like what okay so
that probably didn't happen to you
specifically but I bet somebody's Aunt
sent them that in March of 2019 because
Keanu was on a flight from San Francisco
to LA that had to make an emergency
landing they touched down in Bakersfield
California and everyone was just pretty
much stranded enter Keanu he decided he
would just John Wick the thing and take
charge without any of the killing
naturally after agreeing to take photos
with people at the Bakersfield Airport
and chat with everybody a bit he helped
arrange mini buses to drive everyone
from Bakersfield to Los Angeles and he
didn't just rent his own car or get a
private jet or anything either instead
he hopped on one of the buses and drove
the rest of the way with a bunch of his
fellow passengers and if you're thinking
he probably just popped in some earbuds
or took a nap so no one would bother him
then you don't know Keanu my friend he
started by playing some gentle country
tunes on his phone hoping they would
calm anybody down who was still feeling
anxious about the flight then he started
pulling up facts on his phone about each
town they went past and reading them out
loud like the most lovable tour guide of
all time I think it's fun again I think
that's fun he's not just kind in
emergency van rides and photos either
our respectful King is also a charitable
King because he donates a ton of money
to Charities and apparently he usually
does it in secret so we probably don't
even know that half of it are you ready
to be known Keanu Reeves absolutely not
there was one report that he had donated
31 and a half million bucks to cancer
research one time which was 70 percent
of his earnings from The Matrix his
publicist ended up denying that story
but honestly that might just be his team
trying to keep his charitable giving out
of the spotlight either way we do know
about plenty of places he's helped out
with money appearances and stuff like
that one time he even admitted that he
has a private Foundation which he
started around 2003 that helps cancer
research and children's hospitals he
also admitted that he's never attached
his name to it so it can just do its job
without being pestered by the media he's
donated to score which is an
organization that helps hockey players
who suffer spinal injuries and he put
his body where his money was when he
agreed to play goalie in a charity
hockey game for the foundation and don't
worry Keanu played that position in high
school so he wasn't totally lost and
while he might not attach his name to
some of his giving he also knows he can
use his famous face to help out too like
when he manned the phones at a Telethon
for cancer research when he's not giving
his time and money to Charities he's
giving incredibly generous rap gifts to
the crews and especially his stunt
actors of his movies like he gave custom
Rolexes to the stunt team for John Wick
4. baller and he got Harley Davidsons
for the stuntmen from The Matrix
Reloaded and he's an expensive champagne
to literally everyone who worked on the
first three Matrix movies after the
third one was done and he's also worked
stuff into his actual contracts just to
be kind like he took a pay cut on the
movie Devil's Advocate underrated check
it out so they could afford to hire Al
Pacino not that Al needed the money but
Keanu thought it would be a better movie
with him and he apparently also gave up
points on the back end which is movie
talk for a share of the prophets on the
sequels to The Matrix so that the unsung
heroes like the visual effects folks and
the costume people could make more
that's a pretty huge gesture there's so
many people working who's so talented to
create this world he's also known for
smaller gestures in 2015 A video popped
up on YouTube showing Keanu giving up
his seat on the New York subway to a
woman he noticed was carrying a heavy
bag she took him up on the offer
suddenly an announcement came over the
speakers that the train had to stay
above 50 miles an hour or it would
explode okay fine that part isn't true
but the other stuff is that simple
gesture plus maybe the fact that people
found it wild he was riding the subway
instead of a taxi or limo made the video
go viral and more than 40 million people
have watched it it wasn't all that
amazing of an act to be fair but it's
just a cool reminder of how down to
earth and caring Keanu is we do we can
change lives we can't help it also
started a string of people sharing their
personal stories of interacting with
Keanu and each one was some variation of
meeting him and him being incredibly
nice or like being too shy to talk to
him but having him notice and start the
convo himself stuff like that in fact
another story that went viral in a tweet
thread in 2019 had a similar Vibe a
writer and producer named James detour
posted a story that happened when he was
a teen he was working at a movie theater
in Sydney Australia at the time as he
sat in the ticket booth up walked Keanu
in a cooler jacket and a helmet that
looked like he got off a horse recently
I have no idea why Reeves was rocking
that particular look but he's Keanu and
he can wear what he flipping wants you
guys you do what you want your new waves
anyway James recognized him immediately
in like a normal 16 year old meeting a
celeb got kind of tongue-tied he
desperately wanted to think of a way to
ask Keanu for his autograph but he
couldn't find the Nerf suddenly it hit
him he would offer Keanu his employee
discount and to do that he would need
Keanu to sign the official sheet but
Keanu is like
um yeah no worries mate I don't work
here I'll just pay full price so he
bought a ticket and went in Jason was
bummed a few minutes later he heard a
knock on his door Keanu is back he told
Jason he realized he probably only just
wanted his autograph so Keanu handed him
a receipt that he'd gotten at the
concession stand and signed it for him
then he threw away the ice cream he'd
bought and went to go see the movie in
other words Keanu literally bought ice
cream just to have a piece of paper to
sign for young Jason I mean who does
that a living Angel that's who and that
angel is also a man of his word I know
shocking in August of 2022 he was in the
UK staying at a hotel in
northamptonshire and while that sounds
like a town I just made up it's real it
just so happened there was a wedding
going on while he was there a couple
James and Nikki Road Knight noticed
Keanu at the bar of the falsely Hall
Hotel again real British names and told
him they were going to get married there
that night he's having a drink or a
coffee or whatever he was doing and we
interrupted him and he was so gracious
they invited him to come over and join
them for a drink he politely declined
but said that instead he would pop by
the wedding later that evening now in my
experience when someone promises they'll
totally meet up with you later it's
their nice way of saying they are
definitely not going to see you later
but not Mr Keanu Reeves he keeps his
promises y'all despite having just
arrived from the states a few hours
earlier he stayed up and joined the
wedding reception according to James and
Nikki he posed for photos chatted with
guests and was overall very Keanu about
the whole situation and he was just so
I'm gonna go watch some Kiana movies and
look for hidden clues about how to be
more like him or I'll just enjoy the
movies it's a win-win you guys if you
know of any more stories proving he's
the best person pop them in the comments
section